[Esta charla tiene contenido adulto.
Permanecer en la sala queda a criterio del espectador]
Tiffany Kagure Mugo: Bien.
Nos comprometimos a venir, ya no hay vuelta atrás.
(Risas)
Siphumeze Khundayi: Hola chicos. TKM: Hola a todos.
TKM: Uds. creen que saben de sexo.
Hay cosas que desconocen,
por eso estamos aquí, para explicarles lo que no saben.
SK: Estamos aquí para decirles que no importa de dónde vengan;
desde Abuja a Alabama, desde Dubai hasta del centro de Londres,
el sexo ha cambiado y continúa cambiando.
Y tenemos que entender esto
si queremos que las cosas sigan siendo seguras y picantes.
TKM: El acto de rozarnos con el cuerpo desnudo
ha sufrido una serie de cambios.
Y esos cambios se han visto afectados por muchas ideas.
Incluso Uds. como adultos tienen algunas ideas internalizadas sobre el sexo
que nunca cuestionan.
Algunas buenas, algunas malas y otras muy, muy extrañas.
(Risas)
SK: Cuando permites que alguien te vea desnudo,
¿alguna vez piensas que tus ideas determinarán
si te agrada que te hagan cosquillas en el codo o que te besen los muslos
o que griten el nombre de alguna deidad?
Uno debe hacer control y evaluación interna
para tener una excelente vida sexual.
TKM: Y les diremos cómo tener una gran vida sexual, ¿sí?
Pero lo primero que deben hacer
es desprenderse de las malas ideas que tienen sobre el sexo.
SK: Piensen en las cosas que tenemos que cambiar.
TKM: Y las cosas que debemos incorporar en toda su brillante novedad.
Les vamos a llevar en un viaje de sexo:
las partes malas del sexo, las prácticas sexuales históricamente grandiosas
y el futuro del sexo.
SK: A juzgar por los 7000 millones de personas geniales en este planeta,
los humanos vienen practicando el sexo desde hace mucho tiempo.
Y en grandes cantidades.
Pero esto no significa que seamos realmente buenos en eso.
Por mi cabeza ronda la cultura de violación.
TKM: Cómo la tradición y la cultura limitan las ideas de placer.
SK: O incluso la idea de que el pezón
merece el mismo tratamiento que un DJ manejando las perillas
de su equipo para subir el volumen.
TKM: Una especie de manía del DJ.
SK: Tenemos mucho miedo al sexo.
TKM: Y necesitamos culpar a alguien de nuestro miedo.
A las mujeres y el miedo a cada parte de su anatomía,
a menos que seamos las que usamos su sensualidad.
SK: Piénsenlo.
Pueden estar con alguien y decirle tranquilamente: "Me duele el codo".
Pero prueben con decirle:
"Disculpa, siento una extraña vibración en la vagina,
¿sabes dónde puedo encontrar la pomada para la vibración vaginal?"
Ya verán qué bien se interpreta eso.
(Risas)
TKM: No va bien.
Una vez desafié a mis amigos a ir a los supermercados
y decir a los extraños, "muslos".
Nadie lo hizo,
a pesar de que podrían haberse referido a los muslos de pollo o pavo.
(Risas)
SK: Una serie de nociones culturales e históricas
se han incorporado tan profundamente en nosotros,
que ni siquiera notamos que es extraño que la gente se ponga nerviosa
al escuchar "pezón", a diferencia de "rodilla izquierda".
Nos negamos a relacionarnos con el sexo apropiadamente.
Y el primer paso es admitir que existe
más allá de intentarnos vender productos como agua embotellada o café,
en forma de representaciones poco realistas en las películas
o eso que viste en Internet "por error".
TKM: Ajá.
Y para curar esta dolencia,
admitamos primero que tenemos algunas ideas erróneas sobre el sexo.
SK: Y respiren,
(Inhala)
y dejen que todo fluya.
Parece bastante morboso
que la cultura y la sociedad nos hayan fallado en nuestra búsqueda del coito.
Pero este no es el caso.
Hay cosas que el pasado nos puede enseñar
para ayudarnos a actualizar el presente.
TKM: Si yo tuviera un vaso de Merlot, lo cual realmente desearía tener,
serviría una copa a los antepasados
porque hay formas en que las sociedades africanas
trataban esto del sexo, antes de que la C ... -- que no quiero nombrar--
SK: (Susurrando) Colonización.
TKM: ... existiera.
Dentro de las sociedades africanas,
tuvimos espacios, tanto sociales como espirituales,
que ayudaron a institucionalizar prácticas sexuales saludables.
Tuvimos escuelas de sexualidad que enseñaban pautas sociales y eróticas.
Tuvimos espacios donde los adolescentes podían involucrarse, entender
y aprender cómo manejar las necesidades sexuales,
y lugares donde los adultos podían manejar sus tensiones y conflictos.
SK: Formas que no incluían ocultar la cuenta de tarjeta de crédito
o eliminar ese número gratuito de su teléfono.
Estos espacios de antaño eran muy importantes para las mujeres.
TKM: Había prácticas sexuales africanas que se centraban en las mujeres
y en particular, en su placer.
SK: Y vamos a hablar de uno en particular
llamado "oshunalidad".
TKM: También conocido como el erotismo africano.
Sí, bienvenidos a Thunderdome.
Lo erótico toma diferentes formas
cuando viajas por el mundo.
Ahora vamos a saludar al "Kama Sutra",
el primer libro del mundo sobre los placeres de la vida sensual.
Más que una mera representación de posiciones sexuales contorsionistas,
proporcionó una guía completa sobre cómo vivir una buena vida.
Lo que es particularmente interesante para nosotras
es que se enfoca en las mujeres y crea placer para las mujeres.
TKM: Aclamo al "Kama Sutra", pero volvamos al erótico africano.
SK: Bien, traigámoslo de vuelta.
Nkiru Nzegwu dice que Oshun, que es una orisha del pueblo yoruba,
típicamente asociada con el agua,
la pureza, la fertilidad, el amor y, lo más importante, la sensualidad,
representa una energía transformadora centrada en la mujer
que recorre y anima la vida.
Ella dice que las mujeres que tipifican la fuerza de Oshun
muestran su sexualidad de manera bastante abierta y natural.
Y ella continúa diciendo...
TKM: Aquí tienen esa cita.
"El flujo no tiene por qué dar lugar a la concepción y el nacimiento
y no pone el placer en el centro de la cópula.
Este principio del placer en el corazón de la energía creativa
se conoce metafóricamente como 'miel de Oshun' ".
Lo siento, no quería citarlo mal.
Así que la miel de Oshun y la oshunalidad
reafirman la normalidad del placer sexual y lo erótico.
Oshun, como otras deidades femeninas de la fertilidad en África,
aseguró y enfatizó la importancia de la sexualidad femenina
sin negar la sexualidad masculina.
Tuvimos el Tonga, el Bemba, el Sande
y otras escuelas similares de pensamiento sobre la sexualidad
que enseñaron a mujeres jóvenes sobre el poder de esta fuerza interna.
TKM: Y en el continente africano,
se habla mucho sobre la naturaleza sinérgica del sexo
y cómo se transforma en un bien social.
Por ejemplo, en Ruanda,
existe la idea de que los ríos se reabastecen
cuando una mujer eyacula.
(Risas)
SK: Pero las ideas modernas sobre el sexo se han convertido en una batalla
en la que tratamos de derribarnos los unos a los otros.
TKM: Golpeamos el coño, usamos el sexo como un arma,
jugamos fuerte para ganar, para conquistar,
se trata de una constante lucha de poder.
SK: Y siempre hay un perdedor cuando se libra esta guerra.
TKM: La habilidad de mostrar y explorar abiertamente tu sexualidad y tu sexo
sin que sea una amenaza para los demás
es fundamental en la participación de prácticas sexuales saludables.
SK: Aquí es donde comienza a ponerse realmente bueno.
TKM: ¿Qué significa
reconceptualizar el sexo fuera de la idea del monstruo que se esconde en la noche?
¿Cuál es el potencial para hacer maravillas
en la mesa de la cocina, en una playa solitaria, en el asiento de un auto
o incluso simplemente entre las sábanas?
Aprendiendo del pasado y deslizándonos en el presente,
una teoría radical del sexo
debe identificar, debe describir, explicar y denunciar
opresión sexual e injusticia erótica.
TKM: Y la positividad sexual es uno de los reinos
en el que lo nuevo se puede desempacar y explorar.
SK: Les estamos pidiendo que prueben la miel de Oshun,
se relacionen con nuevas ideas de sexo y placer
para comenzar a construir una nueva identidad
que se sienta más como un vestido ajustado
que como un ataúd de madera que lentamente estrangula nuestra vida.
Hay muchas personas que trazan sus propios caminos sexuales.
Y en HOLAAfrica --
SK: Hacemos sexo y sexualidad en línea.
TKM: Sería insensato no mencionar el reino digital.
Hay mujeres que están en línea, creando conversaciones increíbles,
hablando sobre el clítoris,
de posiciones sexuales y también de cunnilingus.
SK: Me gusta la palabra "cunnilingus".
TKM: Seguro, pero ese no es el tema.
Estas mujeres están resucitando el trabajo de los antepasados
manteniendo algunas conversaciones increíbles
que habían sido previamente enterradas y selladas.
SK: Están haciendo las preguntas que tanto tememos preguntar,
para no terminar en situaciones incómodas.
TKM: Eso es verdad.
Y otro espacio donde se está trazando un nuevo camino sexual
es el de las mujeres "queer" y su gusto por la desviación.
SK: Piensen en "Cincuenta sombras de Grey"
sin el tipo rico y horrible que no entiende lo que es el consentimiento.
(Risas)
TKM: Un subconjunto fascinante de prácticas no convencionales
es el juego de cuerdas.
SK: El Shibari, también conocido como Kinbaku, es el arte japonés de la atadura.
Originalmente utilizado para sujetar a los cautivos,
se sexualizó y se extendió por todo el mundo
como una forma de sujeción respetuosa de estética erótica.
TKM: Y aterrizó en nuestras costas.
¿Quién habría pensado que las mujeres queer africanas
tenían prácticas no convencionales?
Y viniendo de una historia de violencia sexual,
esclavitud y falta de autonomía corporal,
¿no es anticipado?, se preguntarán.
SK: No, no lo es.
Estas mujeres nos han enseñado que a pesar de la oscura historia
que cubre el cuerpo de mujeres de nuestro hermoso continente,
estas mujeres están construyendo de forma activa y bella
lo que el sexo y el placer significa para ellas.
TKM: Lo que no significa que todos tengan que adoptar prácticas no convencionales.
Pero si estas mujeres queer pueden salir de una historia
de violencia sexual, esclavitud, colonización
y toda clase de trampas tradicionales, religiosas y culturales,
y reconceptualizar lo que el sexo y el placer significa para ellas,
entonces Uds. puedes hacerlo también.
SK: Uds. también pueden hacerlo, sí, sí.
Sí, tú puedes.
(Risas)
TKM: Hay que tomar las malas ideas que tenemos sobre el sexo,
y sacarlas de la cabeza,
aferrándose a las buenas y creando otras nuevas
para vincularnos increíblemente
con uno de los actos humanos más prolíficos y naturales
de todos los tiempos.
SK: Se trata de averiguar qué cuenta como un error del sistema.
TKM: A qué llamamos un clásico.
SK: Y qué nuevas características deberíamos agregar.
Los seres humanos tienen mala fama por el avance de su superpoder.
Esto debería contar también para nuestra sexualidad.
TKM: Gracias.
(Aplausos)